I started juggling a long time ago but
long before that I was a golfer and
that's what I was a golfer and as a
golfer and as a kid one of the things
that really sort of seeped into my pores
that I sort of lived my whole life his
process and it's the process of learning
things one of the great things was my
father was an avid golfer but he was a
lefty and he had a real passion for golf
and he also created this whole mythology
about Ben Hogan and various things well
I learned a lot about interesting things
that I knew nothing about at the time
but grew to know know stuff about and
that was the mythology of skill and so
one of the things that I'd love to do is
to explore skill and since Richard put
me on this whole thing with music I'm
supposed to actually be doing a project
with Todd Mac over with the MIT Media
Lab that relates a lot to music but Todd
couldn't come and the project is sort of
somewhere I'm not sure whether it's
happening the way we thought or not but
I'm gonna explore skill and and juggling
and basically visual music I guess okay
you can start the music Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you now juggling can be a lot of
fun playing play with skill and play
with space play with rhythm I'm gonna do
you can turn the mic on now I'm gonna do
a couple of pieces that I do a big piece
in a triangle and these are three
sections from it part of the challenge
was to try to understand rhythm and
space using not just my hands because a
lot of juggling is hand oriented but
using the rhythm of my body and feet and
controlling the balls with my feet
[Music]
[Music]
is this next section with an attempt to
explore space see I think Richard said
something about people that are against
something well a lot of people think
jugglers defy gravity or do stuff well I
kind of from my childhood and golf and
all that it's a process of joining with
forces and so what I like to do is try
to figure out how to join with the space
through the technique so juggling
gravity up-down well if you figure out
what up-and-down really are it's a
complex physical set of skills to be
able to throw a ball down up and
everything but then you add in sideways
[Music]
I look at it I look at it somewhat as a
way when you learn juggling what you
learn is how to feel with your eyes and
see with your hands because you're not
looking at your hands you're looking at
where the balls are are you looking at
the audience so this next part is really
a way of understanding space and rhythm
with the obvious reference to the feet
but it's also where time where the feet
were where the balls were
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so visual music rhythm and complexity
I'm gonna build towards complexity now
juggling three balls is simple and
normal well excuse me for jugglers okay
and remember you're transposing you're
getting into a subculture here and
juggling the balls cross and all that
okay if you keep them in their assigned
paths you got parallel lines of
different heights put in a hopeful even
rhythm then you can change the rhythm
well good Michael you can change the
rhythm to get out of the lights okay
change the rhythm so it's even or you
can go back and change the height now
skill well but you're boxed in if you
could only do it up and down that way so
you got to go after the space down there
[Music]
okay then you're gonna combine them
because then you have the whole spatial
palate in front of you and then you get
crazy
[Applause]
I'm actually gonna ask you to try
something so you got to pay attention
complexity if you spend enough time
doing something you start time slows
down or your skill increases so your
perception perceptions change
it's learning skills like being in a
high speed car crash things slow down as
you learn as you learn as you learned
you may not be able to affect it
it almost drifts on you it goes but
that's the closest approximation I can
have to it so complexity now how many
here are jugglers okay so most of you
are gonna have a similar reaction to
this okay whoever laughed there had to
say what here yeah you understood it
completely right no it looks like a mess
it looks like a mess with a guy there
who's got his hands around that mess
okay well that's what juggling is about
right is being able to do something that
other people can't do or can't
understand all right so that's one way
of doing it which is five balls down
okay another way it's outside and you
can play with the rhythm same pattern
make it faster and smaller make it wider
[Music]
now what I wanted to get to is that
you're all very bright very tactful I
have no idea how computer oriented or
three-dimensionally oriented you are but
let's try something okay so since you
all don't understand what the five ball
pattern is I'm going to give you a
little clue nothing a clue so you get
the pattern right okay no no that's
nothing you're not getting off that easy
all right now do me a favor follow the
ball that I asked you to follow green
yellow pink white okay you can do that
yeah okay now let's actually learn
something or actually let me put you in
that area of learning which is very
insecure you wanna do it yeah okay hands
out in front of you palms up together
what you're gonna learn is this okay so
what I want you to do just listen to me
and do it index finger middle finger
ring little little ring middle index and
then open finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger finger little bit
faster finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger finger finger
finger finger
all right a lot of different learning
processes going on in here one learning
process that I see is this okay another
learning process that I see is this okay
so everybody take a breathe breath in
breath oh okay now one more time and
finger finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger open finger finger
finger finger finger finger finger
finger
okay shake your hands up now I assume a
lot of you spend you spend a lot of time
at a computer okay so what you're doing
is you're going lalala and you're
getting this okay so that's exactly what
I'm gonna ask you to do but in a
slightly different way
you got to combine it so what I want you
to do is fingers I'll tell you what to
do with your fingers same thing but what
I want you to do is also with your eyes
follow the color ball that I asked it
about
okay here we go so we're gonna start off
looking at the white ball and I'm gonna
tell you which color and I'm also gonna
tell you to go with your fingers
okay so white ball and finger finger
finger finger finger finger finger
finger pink
finger finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger green finger finger
finger finger yellow finger finger
finger finger finger finger finger
finger finger finger finger finger
finger all right
how'd you do well okay the reason I want
you to do this because that's actually
what most people face throughout their
lives a moment of learning a moment of
challenge it's a moment that you can't
make sense of why the hell should I
learn this okay does it really have
anything to do with anything in my life
you know I can't decipher is it fun is a
challenging am I supposed to cheat what
are you supposed to do you got somebody
up to here who's that who's the
operative principle of doing that for
his whole life okay
trying to figure that stuff out but is
it gonna get you anywhere it's just a
moment that's all it is a moment okay
I'm gonna change the script for one
second just let me do this I don't need
music for it talking about time in a
moment there's a piece that I recently
developed which was all about that a
moment and what I do as an as a creative
artist is I develop vocabularies or
languages of moving objects what I've
done for you here I developed a lot of
those tricks whatever I put the
choreography together but they're not
original techniques now I'm gonna start
showing you some original techniques
that come from the work that I've
developed okay so a moment how would you
define a moment well as a juggler what I
wanted to do was create something that
was representational of a moment
yeah I'll use that man all right I'm
gonna get on my knees so a moment okay
and what I did as a juggler would say
okay what can I do to make that
something that is dependent on something
else another dynamic so a moment a
moment the travels a moment it separates
and comes back together time how can you
look at time and what are you dedicated
to in exploring a particular thing well
obviously there's something in here and
you can all have a guess as to what it
is there's a mystery there's a mystery
in the moment and it has to settle and
then it's dependent on something else
and that comes to rest just a little
thing about time now this is expanded
into a much bigger piece so I use ramps
of different parabolas that I roll the
balls on while I'm keeping time with
this but I just thought I'd talk about a
moment
all right okay
can we show the video of the triangle
are we ready to do that yes this is the
piece that I told you about it's a much
bigger piece that I do in exploring the
space of a geometric triangle
[Music]
the only thing I'll say about the last
session is if you ever tried juggling
and driving the car with your knees at
120 miles an hour the only other thing
is it was a real shock I always drove
motorcycles and when I bought my first
car it shocked me that it cost three
times more than my parents house
interesting anyway balance constant
movement to find an approach to
stillness cheating balance making up the
rules so you can't cheat so you learn to
fly to approach stillness with different
parts of your body to have a
conversation with it to speak
- listen now it's dependent on rhythm
and keeping the center of balance when
it falls going underneath so there's a
rhythm to it
the rhythm can't get much small
as your skill increases you learn to
find those tinier spaces those tinier
movements now I'm going to show you the
beginnings of a piece that is about
balance in some ways and also Oh
actually if your board not here here's
one use for it you can go with the
sticks one music
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that has a certain kind of balance too
which is all about plumb i apprenticed
as a carpenter's assistant apprentice to
a carpenter and learned about plumb
square and level and they influenced
that and this next piece which I'll do a
little segment of two sticks you can go
it Thanks
which is again exploring space and the
lines need some base
[Music]
working with space and the lines in
space in a different way no let's see
here
I'll come back to that in a second but
working with one ball now what if you
attach something to it or change it this
is a little thing that I made because I
really like the idea of curves and balls
together and then creating space and the
rhythm of space using the surface of the
balls
surface of the arms just a little toy
which leads me to the next thing which
is what do I got here okay all right I'm
actually leading up to something the
newest thing that I'm working on this is
not it
this is exploring geometry and the
rhythm of shape
and what I just did was that work for
the mathematics the diameter and the
circumference sometimes pieces are
mathematical in that way that I look at
a shape and say what about if I use this
in business sometimes life what happens
in life affects my choice of objects
that I try to work with the next piece
that I'm going to do which is the
cylinders piece if you want to get that
up the it has to do with cylinder seals
from about 5,000 years ago which were
stone with the designs that were used to
roll over wet clay with all sorts of
great designs I love ceramics and all
that it's a combination of that the
beauty of that that the shape and the
stories that were involved in it as well
as the fact they protected the contents
the second influence on this piece came
from recycling and looking into a tin
can recycling bin and seeing all that
beautiful emptiness so if you want to go
the music for cylinders
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
talking about geometry and everything if
you take the circle and you split it in
half
can you run a skirt music I'm gonna do
just a short version of it circle split
in half and rotate it and mythology
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway that piece also has a kinetic
sculpture in the middle of it I dance
around a small stage so um two minutes
just to end the latest piece that I'm
working on what I love is that I never
know what I'm working on why I'm working
on it they're not ideas their instincts
and the latest thing that I'm working on
[Music]
is something really I don't know what it
is yet and that's good I like not to
know for as long as possible well
because then it tells me the truth
instead of me imposing the truth and
what it is is working with both positive
negative space but also with these
curves and what it involves and I don't
know if my hands are to beat enough to
do it or not but I'll do a little bit of
it it initially started off with me
stacking these things bunches of them
and then playing with the sense of space
of filling in the space and then it
started changing
and become folding on themselves and
then changing levels because my attempt
is to make visual instruments not to
just make now I'll try one other things
to work in three dimensions with your
perceptions of space and time now I
don't know exactly where it's going but
I've got a bit of a bit of effort
involved in this thing and it's gonna
change as I go through it but I really
like it feels right this may not be the
right shape and I have low look at this
shape and then I'll show you the last
the first design ever put to it just to
see just a play because I'm I love all
different kinds of things to play with
let's see here
to work with the positive and negative
in a different way and to change and to
change so I'm off on my new direction
with this to explore rhythm in space
we'll see what I can offer thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you